franklo9 great question from him
did the giants draft a trade with the
bears set them up
for a trade for a quarterback in 2022
such as a russell wilson and you think
about it the giants picked up
chicago's first rounder next year
they'll have their own
you could throw in 20 23 there's your
three
and whether it's russell wilson remember
he was linked to the giants
a couple of years ago when the rumor
mill was starting to churn as russell
was trying to get that big new contract
the giants did come up
in that conversation at the time or it
could be desean watson
or it could be aaron rodgers it could be
anybody because this is the upper out
year for daniel jones
no more excuses for daniel jones after
they give kenny galladay all that money
they draft cadarius tony they've got
sequon barkley
they've got weapons galore offensively
they want to see a josh allen type of a
jump from daniel jones and if it doesn't
happen shereen
i think everything's on the table for
next year including packaging first
round picks
to go get russell wilson or desean
watson
or aaron rodgers or whatever other
quarterback that's out there that we
think is happy
decides he wants a fresh start somewhere
else
mike i love what some of these teams
have done
washington the giants the broncos
perhaps the raiders although they have
cars so their situation is a little bit
different but some of these teams
who we know have an obvious need for a
quarterback and they sat back
and they preach patient patience you
look at ron rivera
preach patience about finding that
quarterback
and the some of these teams are going to
end up with a desean watson
or russell wilson or an aaron rodgers
and they're going to be better for it
and they're going to be better than some
of these quarterbacks who were drafted i
realize these guys are younger but we
see it every year mike
these quarterbacks come into the draft
and they don't mike make it and that's
where daniel jones is right now
we talk about the injuries all we want
joe judge went on his injuries were
serious 90
of the players in the league would have
had to sit out from these injuries he
didn't have saquon barkley he didn't
have this he didn't have that
it's all done now go get it done this
year or you will be replaced next year
and i think the giants will be sitting
pretty
when it comes to finding a quarterback
next year if he doesn't get it done this
year
and and you know what something occurred
to me
we had carson wentz went out of
philadelphia he got out of philadelphia
we had russell wilson want out of
seattle that has
dissipated for now deshaun watson
wanting out of houston that's dissipated
for different reasons
aaron rodgers wanting out of green bay
that's four out of 32 starting
quarterbacks
who's the next wave of young quarterback
that wants out when matthew stafford
went out of detroit and got out so
there's five
who's the next wave of established
quarterback that wants out
i think it's foolish to not at least be
wondering i'm not going to name names
here
we all have access to the standings you
can look at the 32 teams
you can consider the quarterback
situations and i think the broader
message here
is that all these other quarterbacks are
watching this
and you get unhappy with your situation
shireen
you you start rattling the cage you want
out
you won out you want out and you do it
privately you do it publicly you do a
little bit of both but
as more and more guys are doing it more
and more guys who aren't happy with
their teams
are going to feel emboldened to do it
and a lot of it's going to depend upon
how good the team is around him and how
much they're listening
to him couple of factors and and third
how much he gets paid how much he paid
how much he listened to him and how good
the talent is around him
guys could say i'd rather go somewhere
else here's a question that came in via
email from matthew in england i want to
touch on this one because i like this
not that i endorse it but it's something
that other players have done
in other cities and other settings could
aaron rodgers
show up and claim an injury so that he
gets paid and still keeps leverage by
refusing to play this is holding in
you can hold out or you can hold in and
there have been guys over the years
who will show up and will
either not play through an injury that
they otherwise would play through if
they were happy
or just flat out sorry
oh my back guys have done that guys have
done that
i don't think aaron rodgers i think if
he's there he's going to play
but it is a weapon that's available to
players and it's very hard for teams to
deal with it because then you have to be
the one to be the
the bad guy who suggests the guy who's
injured who claims he's injured really
isn't how are you going to prove that he
isn't
yeah well go back to jail ramsay i can't
remember how many injuries he went
through
before he finally got his trade to the
rams right mike but he got his trade to
the rams it happened and so
guys certainly can do that not a
proponent of it but
they have done it they will do it in it
and it's a way for them to get their way
and it's worked it's proven i'm
surprised more guys haven't
taken advantage of and again i'm not
saying that
i would agree with this approach but you
got millions of dollars at stake here
i'm surprised more guys haven't taken
advantage of
you know i i'm dizzy today i think i may
have gotten a concussion in the game the
other day
well how are you doing today well i'm
still having headaches i mean how do you
how do you disprove that
and i think guys use soft tissue
injuries to that effect you know the
hamstring
is usually one of the things that can
linger and linger and linger
so uh i i i i we're on the same page we
don't condone it but be
naive to think it never happens i'd be
stunned if it happens with aaron rodgers
i don't think he would do something like
that
shireen no i absolutely i think aaron
rodgers shows up and he's going to be
all in if he shows up the question is
is he going to show up mike and i think
the answer right now as we sit here
today is probably no
yeah i i agree with you if he's there
he's all in
the question is will he be there and
we'll find out sooner rather than later
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports